Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still blazing
a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
I came back to New York City
with my dream
to transform a staple
of my Argentinean culture.
...by working smart...
The wedge‐based barrier
makes your door
10 times stronger.
...by thinking big.
Created this idea as a part
of a class project at Clemson.
Narrator: We're celebrating
a decade of dreams.
Who's ready
to join our awesome ride?
[ All scream ]
And it all starts now.
Your dream is in the way
of your pocketbook.
My family's gonna
come in here and tackle you.
[ Laughs ]
Do this deal.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the tank
is an entrepreneur
who wants to bring
a traditional Argentinean snack
to the American masses.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Ariel Barbouth.
I am originally from Argentina,
and my company is Nuchas.
Nine years ago,
I came to New York City
with my wife, Leni, $9,000,
this cricket
on my shoulder,
and a dream to transform
a staple
of my Argentinean culture,
the iconic empanada,
into a gourmet meal ‐‐
so delicious, so convenient.
The concept of handheld foods
is universal.
We bring amazing recipes
from all over the world,
use some of the best ingredients
out there,
and bake them inside delicious,
edible pockets.
No plates, no forks, no fuss.
From our slow‐braised
short rib
to our shrimp jambalaya
or our vegan shiitake curry,
Nuchas is on a mission
to bring the world together
through unique flavors
that remind us how delicious
our differences can be.
Sharks, you can join
the Nuchas family today
with an investment of $2 million
for 8% of all this goodness.
[ Sharks "Ohh" ]
Holy ‐‐ What the...?
It is Nuchas' time.
O'Leary: It better be Nuchas
muchas guchas.
$2 million for 8%?
Ay, Chihuahua,
caramba.
I don't want to eat it.
It's too expensive.
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Do you have forks or napkins,
when you're done?
O'Leary: You don't need them.
Barbouth: Eh, I don't.
At that valuation,
you should have forks.
[ Chuckles ]
Mmm.
‐Thank you.
‐There.
There all different flavors.
‐That's very good.
‐Mmm.
‐Chicken's a knockout.
‐Thank you.
‐So $2 million for 8%.
‐Yes.
Tell us about your sales.
So this year,
we're doing $5 million.
[ Garbled ]
$5 million in sales?
In sales.
So our business
consists of two parts.
Wow.
We have our retail part.
We're the first brand
ever to open a kiosk
in the middle
of Times Square.
So that's how we started.
‐That's amazing.
So how much
did you do there?
We do $800,000. It depends.
‐I walk by it often.
‐Yeah.
And I never stop by
because it's so crowded.
The line is so long.
‐Great.
So that's a good thing.
‐What a great testimony.
Currently,
we have three locations,
and we actually have a map.
Eh...all of them
are in iconic locations.
So is this business
solely that?
No.
So out of the $5 million
in sales,
$2 million are from retail
and $3 million are wholesales
to third parties.
If I were to walk up
and buy one,
what does one cost me?
So these will cost you $4.
The short rib will be $5.
And your wholesale?
On the wholesale side
of the business,
which is, really, the one
that is growing like crazy,
we're doing 44%.
It cost us $0.84 to make it,
all in,
and we sell it at $1.52.
What are you gonna make
pre‐tax?
We're gonna make $750,000 profit
this year.
Wow.
And what do you think
next year?
So, next year, we're gonna do
around $12 million in sales,
and we're gonna do around
$3 million in profit.
So, Ariel, you strike me like
you're doing very well.
Why would you need
a Shark?
Now it's fulfillment.
We bought an 8,000‐square‐feet
facility 3 years ago.
We set up the facility initially
just to make raw products.
But currently,
we're at capacity constraint.
You need the $2 million to build
production capacity.
‐We own the kitchen already.
‐What ‐‐ so ‐‐
So we need to improve
the kitchen.
But when successful
restaurateurs
pass $2 million,
$3 million in revenue a year,
they go to the co‐packer market
for capacity that you rent.
Why would you burn $2 million
into capital expenditure?
Because it never
works out.
I've seen so many of my
entrepreneurs do it.
So many.
Unless you control your
own kitchen, you never
control your business.
It never works out.
And if ‐‐ and if I c‐‐ can talk
a little bit about myself,
I'm a manufacturing engineer.
Like, I love ‐‐
So you think no one else
can make these
the way you make them?
‐No.
I mean, you will find
empanadas everywhere.
I think almost everybody
that comes from Latin America
has thought of starting
their own empanada business.
Yes, that's true.
I know two people.
‐Everyone.
It's easy
to start a business.
It's really hard
to make one successful.
Well said.
Ariel, how do I get
my money back?
So we're growing really fast.
The opportunity's endless.
The wholesale part, we're ‐‐
we're doing amazingly well.
We sell at gourmet stores like
Whole Foods, Gourmet Garage.
So you're not under the Nuchas
name in those stores.
You are under ‐‐ that store
is just putting them out.
So we private label
for some of the stores.
So the idea
with this investment
is we'll bring up our
manufacturing capacity
from the current level
of 100,000 units
to 300,000 units a week.
Where are you gonna sell
the additional 200,000 units?
We've already had the
conversations,
and we've been negotiating
with ‐‐ with some airlines,
and the capac‐‐
‐How can the airline deal
have the same margins
as the retail business?
‐No way.
‐It can't.
No, no. So but ‐‐
but it's ‐‐ the ‐‐
Ariel, that ‐‐ that ‐‐ that
is just such an expensive bet.
You're talking to airlines so
you can sell 200,000 more units.
I would not approach it
that way at all.
You're asking for $2 million,
and that, effectively, is
we're all in on scaling
your wholesale business.
That's just not a ride
I‐I'm willing to make.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
But congratulations on what
you've accomplished.
I really appreciate it.
How many trucks do you own?
I only have one truck.
‐Only one truck?
‐Cart. They're carts.
‐One truck.
‐Oh, I'm calling them "carts."
‐The other three are kiosks.
‐I'm sorry.
The retail part
is a difficult part.
It's not growing exponentially.
I do believe 100%
with the core of my soul
that this is a category
that somebody's going to own.
So, how much are you losing
on the kiosks?
No, we're not losing.
We're breaking even.
‐How much you making, then?
‐What's your profit?
‐We're breaking even.
‐Right, but if you ‐‐
i‐i‐if you want to really
compete and have some longevity
for maybe an acquisition
or something else,
you're gonna need
to brand it
and start doing
consumer packaged goods.
That means that your margins
are going to be less
'cause now you got to do
advertising, marketing,
and other things
to support the brand.
But the way we're gonna make
more margins is wholesale.
With this $2 million,
our margins go from 44% to 55%.
Your margins are gonna go down
in the wholesale business,
not up.
‐Yeah.
‐That's what's gonna happen.
‐Well ‐‐
And I'm funding
the lower‐margin business.
I don't like that.
Well, while he's thinking
about that,
um, I will share with you ‐‐
I do think that you came in
for a really big ask.
$2 million for the 8% is very,
very rich for my blood.
So estoy fuera,
which means, you know,
"I'm out."
Thank you.
It's delicious,
but more importantly,
I see your lines.
They're crazy.
But your numbers
are crazy, also.
I need to know that I can get
my money back in...
four years.
For my $2 million
investment,
I would have to ask for...
...25%.
Ay, Chihuahua, carrramba.
Gracias.
[ Laughter ]
‐I was like ‐‐
‐I know gracias means "yes".
Does that mean, yes,
we have a deal?
I actually have to check.
‐You talking to your cricket?
‐Uh, yes.
O'Leary: The cricket?
You're talking to a cricket?
Greiner: Talk to the cricket.
Okay, don't talk to
the cricket too long
with me here, 'cause ‐‐
No, so cricket said thank you.
It is ‐‐
it is too much
for where we're right now.
But you do know that I'm ‐‐
I'm investing in you,
thinking the whole brand's
gonna work.
Those wholesalers can say, "Why
are we paying so much here?
Let's just start
making our own."
You don't have
a brand in there.
It is just a delicious product
in all those retailers.
We're building this into
a $100‐million business...
Ariel.
...within the next
five years or more.
‐Okay.
‐Ariel, would it be right to say
that your heart is in
the wholesale business
and not
in the cart business?
No.
The numbers don't say any differently.
Sure sounds like it, yeah.
Sure, but, uh, I believe
in the brand so much.
I believe in Nuchas. Like ‐‐
‐Okay, well ‐‐
well, here's my offer.
It's a little bit odd,
but I think
it's a good deal for you,
and it's a good deal
for me.
Narrator: Two sharks are out.
Daymond has offered $2 million
for 25% of Ariel's
empanada business, Nuchas,
but Barbara is also interested.
I'll give you $1 million
for your cart business,
and I'll give you
a $1 million loan
against your real estate
on your wholesale business,
but you keep 100%
of the wholesale business.
I have no interest in that.
You're breaking even
on the carts,
whereas my Cousins Maine Lobster
on a cart
are averaging a little bit more
than $1 million a cart.
There's got to be room in there
for a profit,
and I'll buy my product
from your wholesale business,
of course.
Barbara,
are you franchising, too?
Like lobs‐‐
uh, Cousins Maine?
Of course I'll franchise it.
That's how you make
all your money.
Thank you, Barbara,
but we're gonna be back
making a lot of money
on retail.
How many years
will it take you
to make net‐net
a million dollars in cash
off those trucks
that you get
to put in your pocket
and just apply
to your business?
It's ‐‐ It's not ‐‐
Is it that you don't want
to lose the trucks?
I believe in what's gonna happen ‐‐
Corcoran: And you're not
losing your brand.
You're keeping the brand.
Ariel, are you ‐‐
are you even considering
my offer at all?
I'm looking for a partner.
‐Oh, yeah.
‐25%.
‐It's 25%.
‐Daymond, what was your offer?
‐And the answer to 25%,
I cannot even, no.
I could come up to 10%.
‐You what?
‐I ‐‐
‐That's the room you have?
‐I have ‐‐ I have ‐‐
But 25% is ‐‐ it's ‐‐ it's not
even a ‐‐ it's ‐‐ it's so far.
We definitely would not be
good partners,
so I'm gonna take
my deal back.
I'm out.
O'Leary: Ouch.
How much money
do you have in the bank?
I'm just trying
to figure out something.
Right now, $100,000.
That's it?
‐Ooh.
‐Yeah.
‐He needs it.
‐Ooh!
‐He really needs it.
‐Yeah.
I have $2 million
already invested in my
portfolio companies, okay?
It's making me 14%.
Now I take it,
and I give it to you.
Yeah.
I don't think I'm gonna make
14% with you.
You don't have enough cash
to do it.
I'm out.
So, I need an answer.
So the answer is
I cannot do it.
‐Okay.
‐Mistake, Ariel.
Barbouth: I would love
to get you as a partner...
Wow.
...but I‐I'm not prepared
to sell our retail location,
which is really
our marketing money.
You should take her
deal, you know that?
And really think about it.
‐He's not taking the deal.
It's over. Let's move on.
♪♪
Barbouth: Daymond, uh, uh,
listen, we're building a brand.
25% is too much.
I'm prepared to go...12%?
‐That's kind of ‐‐
‐I‐I‐I'm building a portfolio,
and I need the money back
in four years.
I'll be dead in five.
I need it back in four.
We're ‐‐ So, the sales
that we have,
they're ‐‐ they're gonna
generate enough things, like ‐‐
No, I understand,
and you know what?
That's the best thing
about building a brand
and having yourself.
You can make
those decisions.
Yeah.
But when you have
a partner, though,
it's problematic,
so I'm out again.
‐Thank you.
‐Ariel, I just want to give you
one more chance to understand
the mistake you're making.
Sure. Please.
And I'm not that patient.
These are simply front offices
or windows
where I sell
your product for you,
and you don't have to do
a thing.
When we want to go
and franchise,
would I be the one
franchising, or would I ‐‐
Is it no longer mine?
You're never
gonna franchise it.
You don't have the time.
I'm a little confused here,
so...
‐It's a full‐time business.
‐That ‐‐
You could increase
your wholesale business.
The easiest way
is to open up trucks.
But with your focus
on your wholesale,
you'll never get that done
nor the franchise done.
I'm willing
to do that work for you.
Your business will explode
because you have somebody
watching the front side.
O'Leary: But the one thing
you're missing is,
you make a million dollars.
I've never worked this hard
to spend a million dollars in my life ever.
She gives you a million dollars.
What are you gonna do?
Let's do this.
Let's do $2 million.
We go 80/20.
You take 80%, I keep 20%,
and we're partners.
So you're saying it's $2 million
for the truck piece?
It's $2 million a‐and then I ‐‐
Absolutely not.
Ariel, I think the problem
with this deal is...
Yeah.
...you asked
for too much money.
But I'm giving everything
for $1 million.
No, you're only giving
this little piece
that doesn't make any money.
But it's ‐‐ it's ‐‐
it's not a little piece.
Too me, it's a dream.
Your dream is in the way
of your pocketbook.
I love what you've done.
I do not believe
we're good dance partners.
I'm out.
Thank you for coming very much.
‐Good luck.
‐Congratulations, Ariel.
‐Thank you all. Thank you.
♪♪
Wow.
Barbouth: Just to chop my legs
right when
we're starting to soar,
they would have left us
without a purpose.
Nuchas is worth so much more.
A million dollars in cash
when he only has
$100,000 in the bank
could've been a godsend
if his wholesale business
is ready to grow.
John: Of course.
Basically, he felt like
you were turning him
into purely a co‐packer.
‐That's a lot of Nuchas.
‐Empanadas.
‐But his ego was in the way.
‐No, no.
‐In the end, he has heart.
‐His passion, his heart.
Greiner: I think his passion,
his heart, what he built.
That's ego.
♪♪
Narrator: In Season 9,
Scott Houdashell
and Curtis McGill
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for their Easter‐egg decorator,
Eggmazing.
I'm getting a $2 royalty.
But I'm gonna give $1...
Did I hear "royalty"?
...to some type
of children's organization.
Narrator:
Let's see how they're doing now.
McGill:
When we pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we'd done $150,000 in sales.
It's been less than a year,
and we've gone over $12 million
in retail sales.
Within a few weeks of airing,
we became number one on
Amazon's toys‐and‐craft list.
We'll be launching
in 2,500 Walmart stores
across the nation ‐‐
our biggest deal to date.
Greiner: When you're lucky
enough to be successful,
it's so important to give back.
Houdashell:
The royalty structure wasn't
exactly what we had in mind,
but when Lori mentioned
a donation
back to a children's charity,
that's when we knew
we had the right Shark.
Let the fun begin.
McGill: Today, we're having
a huge egg‐decorating party
for kids here in Amarillo,
and we've invited
Make‐A‐Wish North Texas
to receive
our first donation.
We would like to donate $50,000
today to Make‐A‐Wish.
Thank you for making
wishes come true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo!
Make‐A‐Wish was just shy of
hitting their goals this year,
and this $50,000
put them over the top.
You know, a wish
can help them feel better
and sometimes
even get better, too.
So thank you again for all
that you've done for us.
We sincerely appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
I'm getting in
on this, buddy.
McGill: My nephew, Ethan,
was diagnosed with leukemia
a year and a half ago.
His wish was granted
this last year,
and he got to go Jedi training
at Disneyland.
What Make‐A‐Wish
has done for him
has touched our family
and touched our heart.
Ah, thank you.
The "Shark Tank" experience
has been amazing
for both of us.
We never thought we'd have
a thriving business ‐‐
have the opportunity
to give back.
It's just
an extraordinary feeling.
All: It's Eggmazing!
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the tank
is a product
to keep intruders out.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Alex Bertelli,
and I'm a former Army
special operations
helicopter pilot
and the C. E. O. of HAVEN,
the world's
strongest smart lock.
And my name is Clay Banks.
I'm the C. O. O. of HAVEN.
We're from
Nashville, Tennessee,
and we're seeking $500,000
in exchange for 6% equity
in our business.
‐6%?
‐Sharks, not long ago,
Clay and I both experienced
a series of break‐ins
in our neighborhoods.
In reality, a break‐in occurs
every 18 seconds
here in the United States.
We quickly realized
it doesn't matter
if you lock your doors
or not.
The traditional dead bolt just
isn't getting the job done.
Let me show you.
Banks: This is your standard
dead bolt.
While it may feel secure,
when you lock it,
an experienced intruder
can get in
in about five kicks.
Alex, show them
how easy this is.
[ Door jostles ]
Come on, Alex.
Kick it hard.
[ Door jostles ]
[ Laughter ]
Come on, Alex.
‐[ Chanting "Alex, Alex" ]
‐Come on, Alex. Kick it.
[ Grunts ]
How much you sell
the dead locks for?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Come in! [ Laughs ]
Well, looks like we don't need
to buy this product.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sharks "Oh!" ]
‐There you go.
‐[Indistinct].
‐Oh, he's getting mad now.
‐[ Laughing ]
He took it ‐‐
And, actually,
a break‐in occurs
every 18 seconds
in the United States.
[ Laughter ]
But the doorknob's
about to fall.
‐[ Laughing ] Oh, my.
‐Oh.
[ Laughter ]
‐Yeah!
‐All right!
‐That's persistence.
‐Are you okay? [ Laughs ]
‐This isn't going well.
‐Are you ‐‐
Typically, a break‐in can happen
in less than two minutes
in the United States.
[ Laughter ]
1 in 36 homes in America
will have a break‐in.
Smart locks based at
the dead bolt are no better.
Alex?
[ Panting ] Sure.
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna show you
how HAVEN works.
As you can tell, I'm not
an experienced intruder.
Greiner: Are you okay?
I'm good.
Okay.
But show them how
HAVEN works, Clay.
Yeah.
Cuban: Oh.
[ Laughs ]
HAVEN sits at the bottom
of the floor...
Best pitch ever.
...right next to
the existing threshold.
When activated, the wedge‐based
barrier lifts up.
Using simple physics,
this makes your entire door
10 times stronger to
preventing home break‐ins.
To use it, you simply step on
the gate to open the door.
To shut the door,
you lock it with the gate
with the foot pedal.
And you can see...
[ Door rattling ]
...there's no dead bolt here,
right?
So, Alex,
show them how it goes.
Kick, Alex. [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Exhales sharply ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Do the flying kick, Alex.
All right, Sharks.
Oh, no.
Yay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He finally got it.
That's right, baby.
‐We don't give up.
‐That's right. We don't give up.
‐Absolutely.
‐Oh, my God.
HAVEN is still standing strong.
We've got some demos
we'll show you.
Alex, you've just gone down
in Shark Tank history.
[ Chuckles ]
You will be memorialized
forever.
This is the connected version,
Mark.
You okay?
Hell yeah.
Here you go.
Cool.
[ Exhales sharply ]
All right, I'm gonna grab
a quick drink of water.
Clay, why don't you start?
[ Laughter ]
So, Sharks, we've got two
products that we manufacture.
We have a HAVEN mechanical ‐‐
Mech that you have on this side.
We have
an electronic‐controlled one,
and Mark's got it down here
on this side.
That's pretty cool.
It's got a key fob
just like you have
with your car.
Yeah.
It also has a smart phone app,
where you can share eKEYs.
I would be able
to send you access
to my house,
schedule that.
I would get notification
when you come and go.
What does each cost?
So our cost for
the mechanical‐only one,
we sell it on our website
for $182.
It cost us $67 to make it.
Our landed cost is $82.
Our profit margin
on that is 55%.
What about
the Bluetooth version?
How much?
Okay, the Connect version
we sell for $349
on our website.
Right now, cost of goods sold
is $175.
Wow.
That's a lot.
That's expensive.
Banks: We think we can
get that down.
It's our ‐‐ our first batch
of production at that cost.
Okay.
Do you have a patent
issued on this yet?
Yes, sir, we just got issuance
from the U. K.
We're still pending in ‐‐
in the U. S., uh ‐‐
There's nothing like this
that's on the floor
and that stops somebody
from entering.
Our patents actually cover
the entire door
and for sliding doors.
So, could you do it
at the top, too?
Yes, ma'am.
So that's the other
exciting thing
we want
to tell you about,
is, due to recent
current events
schools started
approaching us
to put this in individual
classrooms.
Oh, wow.
Huge market.
There's over
115,000 schools
in this country, and classrooms ‐‐
This is to protect
the classroom
from anybody getting in?
Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
Our plan is to lock down a
classroom within one second
and give teachers access
and give, uh,
security resource officers,
SWAT team access
to the lock.
It's actually
a really good idea.
That's a great idea.
I don't think you told us
what our ‐‐
your sales were.
Okay, so,
so far, we just crossed
the $250,000 mark
of ‐‐ of total sales.
Where are you
selling them?
We sell online on our ‐‐
on our own website.
How much money have you raised,
and how much debt do you have?
We've raised $1.5 million.
There you go.
‐There it comes.
‐Oh, that's a lot. Wow.
And how much debt
do you have, if any?
We have, uh, two,
uh, investors
with a convertible note debt
of ‐‐ a total of $500,000.
Here we go.
Are you two the sole owners,
be‐‐ besides the ‐‐
We currently own 25% each,
and then we have investors
on top of that with additional
equity to sell.
So the school situation ‐‐
what is it that you have
underway with schools?
Yes.
Tell them about the purchase
order we got in Arkansas.
So, in ‐‐
in Melbourne, Arkansas,
we installed three locks
about a month ago.
They had an open house.
The parents loved it.
The next day, I got a call from
the superintendent and said,
"I've got 94 classrooms
left to do in this school.
I want to put in an order."
‐Nice.
‐That's a big order.
‐You got the purchase order?
Did they order ‐‐
did they order 94?
Yes, ma'am.
What are you gonna
do with the money?
Sure, so our biggest problem
is inventory, simply.
So we're gonna use part
of your investment
to go out and scale inventory
with our suppliers.
Guys, look, I think what
you've done is brilliant.
Well, Mark, let's ‐‐
let's do a deal.
But the challenge is
that your economics are awful.
Your margins are awful
to support what you ‐‐
what you need to do.
We're ‐‐ We're just starting
our manufacturing.
We have made 2,000 locks
and got those
into the customers.
We paid way over
for those first 2,000.
We're not gonna pay that
for the next 10,000
or the next 20,000.
I think you're gonna have
a‐a pretty hard time
figuring out how
to get to scale
and figuring out what works
and what doesn't.
I don't want to be part
of the journey.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you for your time.
Corcoran: I think you have
a huge mountain to climb
and something that I don't think
we'd get our money back,
so, for me, I'm out.
Thank you, Barbara.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate your time.
Thank you for the pitch.
Yeah, guys, I just think
it's gonna be difficult,
particularly from
a cash‐flow perspective.
It's gonna take you
raising your price, you know,
to generate the margins
until your costs come down,
and even then, the ‐‐ the
margins just aren't there, guys.
I'm out.
Sure.
Greiner:
I think this is really smart.
The problem for me is I like to
really understand a product
when I invest in it,
and you might be too early.
I can't invest at this point.
So I'm sorry. I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you very much
for your time.
You know what?
Come on, Daymond.
Let's do a deal.
I'm very interested in it,
but sometimes it's ‐‐
it's what's in the best interest
for the entrepreneur, too.
I can give you a Shark deal,
then you may have
to raise more capital,
and then you get diluted.
Well, give them something
to start with.
What do you want to ‐‐
‐Let them decide.
The only reason we're here
is to get one of you
on this team to guide us,
to mentor us,
to get us into
distribution opportunities
and help scale
our costs down.
We want you on this team.
You're not gonna like
what I'm gonna say
because me taking more of
the company than you own
is not in your best interest,
and I need you to be
a little selfish for yourself.
So I'm not gonna
give you an offer.
I'm out.
Banks:
Thank you, Daymond.
Thank you, Sharks.
Cuban: Good luck, guys.
Congratulations.
Good luck, guys.
I will be a customer for sure.
I am definitely a customer, though.
Banks: This isn't our
first objection.
It is not gonna
be our last.
But there's a problem out there
we're solving,
and we're gonna
keep going after it.
We're gonna continue on.
Uh, t‐the team follows the motto
that I lived in the Army.
We're never gonna quit.
We have paying customers
out there,
not only residentially
but commercially,
and we're gonna keep going.
The impact that "Shark Tank"
has had on my business
has been truly profound.
Barbara's mentorship gave me
the skills I needed
to not only sell my first
invention, AVA the Elephant,
all over the world,
but to now own and operate
a full product‐design
and distribution company.
That is pretty incredible.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a trio
who came up with a solution
to their chronic problem.
♪♪
Beer, please.
Hi, Sharks. I'm Logan.
I'm Austin.
And I'm Teddy, but y'all
can call me Hops,
and we're from Clemson,
South Carolina.
Our company is Kanga, and we're
seeking a $100,000 investment
for a 10% equity stake.
At Kanga, we're all about
cold drinks and convenience.
Speaking of cold drinks,
take a look at this cooler.
I take this thing with me
everywhere.
Since it weighs 50 pounds
and costs hundreds of dollars,
I can't afford to go to the gym,
and I don't need to.
This is my workout.
Both:
He thinks he works out.
[ Laughter ]
But the best part
about it
is that it keeps my beer cold
for two whole weeks.
Hey, man, if it takes you
two weeks to finish your beer,
we've got to have
a separate conversation.
[ Chuckles ]
I don't know about you,
Sharks,
but that doesn't sound
convenient to me.
But there's always
option number two.
My good friend, the old,
trusty, Styrofoam cooler.
Cuban: Oh.
Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
That's definitely
not convenient,
but do you know what is?
The Kanga Kase Mate.
The Kase Mate is a
patent‐pending insulating sleeve
made to wrap around
a cold case of beer or soda
and keep it cold
for up to seven hours
without ice.
And trust me, Sharks,
it's way cooler than a cooler.
It's like a can insulator
for your case of beer,
and using it is easier than
Mr. Wonderful washing his hair.
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] So corny.
All you have to do
is go over to the fridge,
grab a cold case
of beer or soda,
slip it into the Kase Mate,
zip it up,
then you're ready to go.
Think about it, Sharks.
If the case of beer
is already cold
when you get it,
why not just keep it cold
the entire time
you're actually
going to drink it?
Don't let the struggle with ice
make your good time not so nice.
We're Kanga.
‐All right.
‐[ Laughs ] Good job.
We're flipping excited
to be here.
And we know you'll be
flipping excited, too,
when we give you
your very own custom Kase Mate.
Who wants a beer?
‐We do.
‐Here you go.
‐Mr. Wonderful design.
‐Thank you.
‐Aww, thank you.
‐Barbara.
‐Whoa.
That's what I like.
Here you go, Mark.
There you go.
Oh, that's cool. I can get it
from just opening up the top.
Oh.
Very nice.
Hey, cheers to Season 10.
‐You got it.
‐Thank you.
‐That's right. Cheers.
‐That's what's up.
‐Cheers.
There's a lot of different
things that keep beers cool,
as you've pointed out here.
Very competitive market.
Do you have any sales?
We sure do.
Uh, we actually have
$103,000 in sales.
We've only been in business
for about six months.
Six months?
Mostly in Clemson,
or where are you selling them?
So we have two main
distribution channels.
The first is our e‐commerce,
which we launched a Kickstarter
that ran for two months.
That's done about 30%
of our sales.
The other 70% of our sales have
come from our "B"‐to‐"B" route,
or custom wholesale,
as we like to call it,
where we partner with companies
that want to have their logo
featured on our product.
How did you come up
with this?
Lawrence: So, we actually
created this idea
as a part of a class project
at Clemson.
We had to create a solution
for a problem we faced.
So I'm sitting there on game day
in Clemson, South Carolina,
drinking warm beer from a case.
Why was I drinking warm beer
from a case?
Me and all my buddies
had coolers
that cost hundreds of dollars
and keep our beer cold
for a week.
Why couldn't we use it
for a couple hours?
Well, the reason was we had
to walk a mile and a half
to the tailgate
from our apartment.
We didn't want to take the big,
bulky cooler with us,
deal with all the ice.
So we just stopped by a
convenience store on the way,
grabbed a case, and drank it
as it got warm.
So we found the problem, but
where was the solution?
And that's when I started
looking around.
I saw at a tailgate next to us,
somebody took a cold beer
from a cooler
and put it in a can insulator.
That's when it hit me.
Why don't we have the same thing
for the entire case of beer?
How long does it stay cold?
Seven hours.
So how much do you
sell this for,
custom and ‐‐
and just off the shelf,
and what's it cost you?
We sell at retail,
the 12‐pack, for $29.95,
the 24‐ and 30‐pack for $34.95,
and our custom channels average
about $20 per unit.
Now, our cost of goods average
$6.10, and $3.50
is how much it costs us
right now to land it.
We know we can get ‐‐
Okay, $9.60 total.
‐Yeah.
‐What's special about the lining
on the product that
keeps it cold,
or is it like every other
thermos lining?
What's really exciting,
actually,
about this entire package
is, intuitively,
the actual cardboard case adds
some level of insulation.
So it's t‐the combination of
that cardboard casing then a s‐‐
a liner that acts as
a‐a watertight barrier
and, uh, prevents any air
from getting in and out.
And then the foam layer
actually adds a little bit
of an air gap to it.
We have two patents filed.
We're pending on both.
There's a channel you haven't
talked about, which is going to
the beer companies
themselves.
I'm glad you asked.
So we were actually
approached
by the largest brewery
in the world,
and they wanted
to put their logo
for their three top brands
all over our product.
As of last week, we have
a purchase order in hand
from Anheuser‐Busch.
‐That's fabulous.
‐How much?
It's for $16,000.
It is a test market only,
but they have expressed that
if they like these units,
they want to order 10,000.
Corcoran: Good for you.
How much money have you
put into the business?
So, personally, we've all
put $833 into the business.
[ Laughter ]
John: Nice!
We're broke college students.
We do what we can.
Yo!
Maxwell: We're swimming ‐‐
we're swimming in student loans
right now, and, uh, I just
graduated in December,
and Logan just graduated
a couple weeks ago.
This show, actually,
has inspired me
to pursue entrepreneurship.
So I'm a diehard fan.
I'll be honest.
I've seen every episode.
I've seen your bald head
plenty of times, Mr. Wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
And ‐‐ and I love it.
And I love it.
So, back ‐‐ back in Season 6,
in October of 2014,
I was watching
a live episode,
and I saw a company come on
and make a deal.
Uh, I actually
called the CEO
the night
that the episode aired
to explain to him how I could
provide value to them,
and I worked my way up with this
company from a customer
to a brand ambassador
to an intern.
And after turning down
multiple engineering offers,
I decided to pursue that
company full‐time.
Are you gonna name
the company?
It's a "Shark Tank" company?
Sure.
It's BeatBox Beverages.
I would've guessed, yeah.
‐Oh.
‐Great guy.
The craziest thing about it
is now I'm up here
and have the opportunity
to present to you guys
with my own company,
and this has already been
a dream come true for me.
Good for you.
And I hope that I'm able
to inspire other people
that are going down
a similar path as I am.
‐That's great.
‐That's good news.
All right, guys,
you know what?
I've done every beer and alcohol
that's come on here.
I'll make you an offer.
All right? It's not a
negotiation, just an offer.
You say yes or no.
I'll give you the $100,000,
but I want 20%.
Yes or no?
You got a deal!
Let's do it!
[ Laughter ]
‐Let's do this.
‐Thank you, Mark.
‐Yes, sir.
‐Let's make it happen.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thanks, Mark.
‐Thank you guys so much.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you so much.
Lawrence: Anybody watching this,
we were in your shoes
a year and a half ago,
and now we're here.
Anything can happen.
Just believe in it.
Go for it.
Be crazy enough to do
something about it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a business that offers
favorite family activities
at a discount.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Jamie Ratner, CEO
and founder of CertifiKID.
And I'm Brian Ratner,
president of CertifiKID.
We're from Potomac,
Maryland.
We are here today seeking
$600,000 in return
for 8% of our company.
Ooh, this is uncomfortable.
Parents are always looking
for new experiences
to make memories with their kids
without breaking the bank.
That's why we created
CertifiKID,
a website and app
that provide amazing deals
on family‐friendly
experiences,
services, and products.
From adventures to classes
to camps,
CertifiKID delivers
amazing experiences
at unbeatable prices.
Once signed up,
CertifiKID e‐mails you
a special parent‐approved offer
each day.
And if that's not enough,
you can always find
more than 300 local and national
exciting deals
on our site at
any one time.
We have deals
for any season,
from a snow‐tubing getaway
in the winter
to a pirate‐cruise birthday
party in the spring.
Kids spa day.
And what summer
would not be complete
without a trip to your local
amusement park?
[ Lori chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty cool‐looking.
[ All scream ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Screaming continues ]
[ Imitating roller coaster ]
[ Laughter ]
Please tell us
they're related to you.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Oh, my goodness.
That's good theater.
All right, Sharks.
Who's ready to join
the unstoppable
CertifiKID family
on our awesome ride?
Together: Whoo!
‐How do you find the events?
‐Okay, I'm ‐‐
O'Leary: I'm very interested.
If I live in Fargo,
do I have activities
around my town?
No, you do not.
Not at this point.
We are currently in
Washington, D. C.,
Baltimore, Chicago, L. A.,
Philadelphia, and Atlanta.
‐That's ‐‐ That's sizable.
‐Which is your biggest city?
Washington, D. C., we're huge.
That's where we're based.
That's your ‐‐ That's where
you're from? Okay.
Yeah.
How do you make your money?
So, when a business
signs up with us,
there's no cost to them.
We take a percentage on
each sale that's sold.
So customers are buying
through our website.
They'll buy a voucher
for a farm festival.
Say it's $15.
They'll pay $10.
We, then, would pay the
business, for example, $5.
So you're,
effectively, Groupon
for a very specific market,
a family market.
Family niche and mom niche,
in particular.
What made you come up
with the idea?
Tell us a little
about this history.
I was running a‐a blog
on the side for fun
that was geared to deals,
and, deep down,
I always wanted to
have a business,
and I was putting away money.
And I told him about this
new daily deal concept,
but it was only spas and
restaurants at the time.
And I said,
"Wouldn't it be awesome
to have a site like this
but geared to moms?"
Keep in mind, I had no
business background,
no I. T. background,
no marketing, no sales,
nothing.
You were a stay‐at‐home mom
at that time?
My background is
criminal‐justice
security management.
Of course it is.
[ Laughter ]
John: Why not?
‐Perfect fit.
‐Interesting.
You have a kid that's out of
line, you put him in prison.
‐Yeah.
‐I'm curious.
What ‐‐ What is your
background?
Um, I'm a lawyer.
My focus is mainly
high‐level business,
strategic, financial.
Brian, if you're
the finance guy...
But you still have
a job as a ‐‐
...what's the revenue?
This year,
more than $5 million.
‐Good for you.
‐What?!
But those are gr‐‐ that's your
gross numbers, right?
‐That is our gross numbers.
‐You sold $5 million worth
of tickets to stuff,
and you kept how much?
Our net income from
that number this year
projected to be
about $700,000.
‐Nice.
‐Wow.
No ki‐‐ I thought this
was poo‐poo on a stick.
Hold on, how about this?
Since we launched in 2010,
we have generated more
than $30 million in sales.
‐Wow.
Have you cut any deals with
the toy companies for products?
So, that's the other side
of the business
is that,
in the last three years,
we added a new element
of the business
where we were doing
paid advertising.
So that's opened up this
enormous revenue model for us.
How often do you send
your newsletter out?
Every day.
We have over a million
subscribers.
Wow.
I would say about
half of those
are, you know,
super engaged.
What's your open for
a typical daily open?
It's a 10% open,
14% click‐through.
‐That's nice.
‐Not bad.
Yeah.
Have you brought
any capital
in from anybody else?
No, we were profitable
after our third month
with the seed money that Jamie
was hiding away for ‐‐
for her business.
Congratulations.
Why do you think you
need an investment?
You've been profitable since
three months opening.
Yes.
Family‐run business.
Yeah.
Why would you want
more capital right now
if you can grow
without having to worry
about anybody else
but the family?
The safe thing for us to do
would be to not be here.
Keep doing what we're doing.
It's a great family business.
Right.
We're doing well.
My father passed away about
a year and a half ago.
‐I'm sorry.
‐Sorry.
Um, he used to say,
"Don't have regrets."
He regretted a lot
of deals he didn't do,
and I think we feel,
at this point in time,
what we see as a strategic
partnership with a Shark
to help guide us
to help us grow the business.
What would
the $600,000 go for?
So, we would use
the $600,000 to help support
our marketing‐and‐sales
strategy,
which would include
growing our sales team,
and also helping us grow
our subscriber base
through customer acquisition.
Cuban: Yeah, that ‐‐ guys,
that's your challenge.
Making $700,000 is no joke,
but the hardest challenge
is refreshing content,
particularly when you have
long‐term customers...
Right.
...you know, because they
love it, love it, love it,
and then, "What have you done
for me lately?"
I just think that ‐‐
that's a big a hurdle.
I‐I don't see the valuation
matching that challenge.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
I'm sorry to hear that,
but thank you.
I believe that, you know,
after eight years of, uh,
making newsletters,
you've already figured out
something, right?
I would offer you $600,000
for 17.5%.
Thank you so much
for that offer.
We really appreciate it.
I think you're overlooking
a tremendous potential
in your business.
I'm interested in a deal,
but only if you believe
in the philosophy that
I see in the business,
which is to turn it
into a franchise.
I think you can make a killing
as a franchise business,
because I think
there are so many moms
who want to be involved
in a mom business
where they're in charge.
Not working for you,
but running their own business.
So I'll make you an offer
for the $600,000,
but I want I want 25%.
Ooh.
But the contingency is,
for your sake and for mine,
to turn it into a franchise.
I could make you a fortune.
‐Uh...
‐Do you capture any data?
For example,
birthdays of the kids.
We ‐‐ That's something
we've discussed.
That is something ‐‐
You haven't done that yet?
Currently, no.
Well, if you had
the birthdays
of the kids,
and I have Lovepop cards,
I need to know that...
Yeah.
...so I can pay you
to give me that data
and sell that product.
Right. I ‐‐
That's where I see huge
opportunity, as well.
'Cause if ‐‐ A lot of these are
birthday gifts to kids, right?
Right, yeah.
No, no, I think there could be
a whole birthday program.
It's something ‐‐
it's on my list.
Wow. There's so much ‐‐
there's a lot of opportunity
in ‐‐ in data mining for you.
Right, yes, yes.
Brian: Absolutely.
I don't see
the franchising thing.
I don't agree with Barbara
at all on that.
I think you're mistaken.
I think you want to
control that database,
'cause that's where
the value is.
I would do the deal,
but on the exit,
here's what I'd like,
because you may be
taking more money
down the road,
and, again, I have no control
'cause I'm a minority
shareholder.
I want to make sure
whatever happens,
I get three times on my money
on the exit.
So I'm gonna help you
build this thing up.
I've got two or three companies,
I think, that would buy this
if the database
got a little better.
Look, if you guaranteed me
three times on my 600K
if there's an exit,
I'd give you the 600K for 20%.
Barbara hasn't thought enough
about it to figure that out.
Uh, let me tell you,
I'm not so stupid.
I don't know what
he's talking about.
I'm not as complicated.
$600,000 with 17.5%,
not all this other crap
they're talking about.
And I'll share with you.
I love you both, but
I kind of feel like you
shouldn't bring in a partner.
I ‐‐ It's just my opinion.
What are you ‐‐
What are you talking about?
Mind your business.
Just my opinion.
I think you have some
very good offers here.
You're doing so amazing.
I feel like you're better off
not giving away equity,
and so for that reason,
I'm out.
So, you still have
three viable offers.
Time to make a decision.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out,
but Brian and Jamie have
three offers on the table
for their daily deal business
for moms and kids, CertifiKID.
Time to make a decision.
What do you want to do?
Kevin, I'd like to counter
to you at $600,000 for 15%.
Look, if I give you $600,000,
I'm gonna work like hell
to make sure I get it back.
I will work with you
to make this big.
Eventually,
you're gonna want to sell it,
no question,
and I get you a huge exit.
That matters to me.
I know what I'm worth.
Would you drop
your contingency?
When you invest in us,
you're gonna get returns
in year one.
You don't need to guarantee
yourself a three times ‐‐
You're gonna get profits
next year, immediately.
Jamie: Tomorrow.
[ Chuckles ] I mean ‐‐
Tomorrow. Trust me.
We have built a phenomenal
business here.
Let's see how
flexible you are.
Meet me in the middle.
I want 20%,
and you're saying 15%.
17.5%, and we have a deal.
Will you drop
your contingency?
No.
The contingency's
a killer.
Kevin, you can do this deal.
$600,000. We c‐‐
I'm starting to like you,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
I think you can do ‐‐
I think you can do
this deal at 15%.
You came in here for Kevin,
so I‐I'm gonna take my offer
off the table.
Oh, you're like a sore loser.
My God.
Oh, interesting.
I'm not. I don't want ‐‐
Listen ‐‐
You're like a baby.
Brian, how about this?
They came here for
somebody, Barb.
How about th‐‐
how about this?
Y‐You're a baby.
I'll stay at 20%.
I remove the pref down
to just one times.
I get my money back
when we sell it.
I'm not asking for
a profit on that.
We ‐‐ We cannot do that.
Kevin, I think you can
do the $600,000 for 15%
without the contingency.
No.
It's an amazing deal.
Amazing deal.
Kevin, this ‐‐
[ Laughing ] You know that.
We are gonna ‐‐ don't not do ‐‐
we are gonna ‐‐
Hey, we're a deal company.
I love you. I love you.
This would be
the best deal you do.
Imagine ‐‐ Imagine ‐‐
It will make you
money immediately.
Brian, if you're asking me
to take the preference off,
it's got to be 20%.
You get the 600K for 20%.
Let's roll.
I like your negotiating style.
You're honest, you're fair,
but I'm stuck with a line
in the sand here.
You know, great deals,
both walk away
having given something up.
Those are great deals.
I'm already crying.
Kevin, we can't ‐‐
You know, tonight, I'm gonna get
under my bed and cry
about my preference.
No, we are gonna
make you money.
I'm a Shark. I'm a Shark.
I know, and we're gonna
make you money.
And we're giving you
a phenomenal premium
on this money.
$600,000 ‐‐
Brian, $600,000, 20%,
done, no preference.
Ready? Let's go, buddy.
Kevin, $600,000.
We will incr‐‐
we'll go to 17.5%
17.5%, your number,
no preference.
We will make you money.
You can do this.
20%. No preference. Done.
This is a great deal
for you.
I'm fighting for this deal.
I'm loving you.
You ‐‐ yes.
So do it.
Brian, done deal.
20%. No preference.
My family is gonna come
in here and tackle you.
Do this deal. 17.5%.
[ Laughter ]
You can do it.
No preference. 17.5%.
Brian, do not walk out of
the Shark Tank for 2.5%.
Oh, my God.
Don't send us out
of here for that.
Come on.
Don't send us out of here.
We're stuck.
[ Chuckles ]
18.5%.
No. 19%. Done.
‐Done.
‐[ Laughs ]
We'll say it. We'll say it.
She's ‐‐ she's got to say it.
Say what?
"It's a deal."
It's a deal.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Mazel tov.
Thank you.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Kevin, we're gonna kill it.
[ Laughter ]
‐I'm loving it.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Well done.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
♪♪
[ Laughs ] Whoo!
Whoo!
Mr. Wonderful!
Brian: It was so amazing
to get three offers,
but we really think
Kevin gets our business,
and we think that
he has the potential
to take us to amazing
new heights.
♪♪